hey everyone welcome to the walleye
podcast episode 100. man that has come
around quick but
it has been awesome having so many lads
come on the podcast and be themselves
and hopefully you guys have enjoyed
hearing what some of these guys are
actually like off the field i've
certainly enjoyed bringing them to you
learnt heaps along the way heaps of cool
journeys that i didn't know about before
getting them on the podcast so it's been
really cool
and if you enjoyed the podcast then
please do me a favor and share any of
the podcasts that you have enjoyed or
you do enjoy in the future
and to go one step further go and get
yourself some woodland merch some more
led coffee or some pure sports cbd
to do so head over to waterlab.com and
all the information is on there but
anyway i have an awesome guest to bring
up the hundredth for you here's one of
the great lads so let's get into it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what a land well guys today is a very
special day as we raise the bet with our
100th guest on what a lad so i knew i
had to get someone on who was very
special potentially one of the biggest
lads and not only rugby but in sport and
i think i've got him he is an olympic
silver medalist he's won the
commonwealth gold twice he's won two
sevens world cups he's won the super
rugby title with the highlanders he's
won the npc premiership with the nike
he's won a championship with hawke's bay
and he's won personality of the year
more times than anyone else on this
planet he is arguably the goat lad and
i'm stoked to have him on what a lad it
is of course the one and only kurt baker
welcome craddo thanks jeremy gebber mate
i know you're in isolation i like to
rope in all my woodland guests while
they're in isolation what have you been
up to not a lot to be honest um early on
after the flight we um
had to catch up on some z so
slept for the first couple of days and
recovered and then
we're at day seven now so it's starting
to get to the point where um sort of out
of ideas or things to do
um
sort of walk around the room pointlessly
but um it's not too bad you got clothes
on though is that regular or are you
usually nude yeah i just top half yeah
yeah just top half
you don't want to see the bottom up for
us
[ __ ] no i've seen that too many times
were you on that um rowdy flight back
were you because i saw an article on uh
some olympic athletes causing a bit of a
party plane surely that was you
well i don't know i know coming but
yeah what's the definition of rally
these days
nude on the air hostess shoulders
nah there
there's one thing i can confirm there's
no nudity yeah thank god yeah you guys
would have just been having a few
few beers on the way back was it yeah i
think well
you could put the people together on
that plane there was some roles that i
think they'd live a pretty dry lifestyle
and you know they've
had some pretty good success in the
olympics he was
like with the surfers they're always up
for a good time oh yeah and then uh
yeah the swimmers came back with us too
so now others
oh there's a good way to finish off a um
pretty epic campaign of like olympians
in new zealand so
um yeah some people
might not have seen it the way we did
but it was a good time and you've been
doing it you've been doing a couple of
uh marathons with clarky to keep keep
yourself busy keep your days full
yeah yeah this good idea at the start um
he'd do 42 cases down the bike but
you've seen the bikes that we're
operating um starting to get a dicky
left now yeah so i pulled it out
i don't think it's worth it how many did
you do
i did four um
and then oh today i just did a circuit
and i jumped on the bike so i sort of
told myself that was as good as
doing 42k but it's probably 4.2k
oh anyway we'll get to your um olympics
journey so how'd you find it silver
medal uh you obviously wanted to go one
better but um you still must have felt
proud that you got to the final and you
got to come home with a silver
yeah well it is a funny one i think like
at the time obviously disappointed with
like i suppose all rugby players in new
zealand got pretty high expectations of
themselves and their teams yeah so you
know initially were disappointed but
um you know the more we talked about it
and the more we
actually realized what it was it wasn't
just us you know a second at a world
series tournament it was a olympics and
you know people have trained five years
to get to that point like us and it's a
funny one like it's just because i think
you play a final when someone's going to
lose but if you just say it was a yeah
i know a road race and you had first
second third i guarantee the second
person would be rap so it's just
the sport we play and um
yeah i suppose if you compare it to the
last number campaign you'd um
you take it with arms wide open because
we're a far away from the silver there
100
what was it like in the changing rooms
after was it
a pretty sour vibe or was it still
pretty upbeat not sour i think it was
just boys were just gutted because we
we knew we were capable of a lot more
than probably how we went um against the
fijian boys um yeah and you know a lot
of outsiders looking and said all the
fijian boys played really well and they
actually did but i think just because
we've got such high expectations of
ourselves it was
a bit of disappointment if it was being
honest but yeah i suppose it's just
rugby and sport in general like
someone's gotta lose and someone's gonna
be pissed off about it so yeah you must
have been itching to get on i mean there
was a moment there i was waiting for the
cradle number to come on and bring the
boys home but didn't get as many minutes
as you probably would have hoped no i
didn't and you know i suppose that again
a sport because other tournaments i've
had
plenty of minutes so um i suppose that
tournament just wasn't mine but we
always talked about we had a real strong
12
which we think a lot of the other teams
didn't so yeah
if i was a part of that 12 and i could
you know make a difference to our team
then you know it was worth it um
yeah probably early on there's just
some big old shifts on d so
we made it pretty hard but if i meant
that some boys had some legs at the end
of the tournament then so bad um yeah
there were a pretty good bunch of boys
around you know what's best for the crew
and you know i feel like we've genuinely
got a bloody strong squad so you can
suck it up when you you've got decent
players around you and you did your
build up into the tournament wasn't
exactly smooth was it you you went into
the tournament with a little bit of a
niggle do you want to talk about that
yeah either way i had a few hiccups like
um real early on in the year the
achilles were playing up so i stood off
feet for quite a while yeah came back i
was getting into it and then pulled my
calf about maybe six weeks out from us
leaving for the olympics so
the road got a bit bumpier and then so
off feed again um so i didn't spend a
lot of time on the field prior to
leaving and then we obviously went to um
townsville for the oceania tournament
and
that didn't pan out so well either the
um the last training before the
captain's run i rolled my ankle and
saw the ligaments on the outside of my
ankles so
that was obviously two days out from the
tournament starting so we made life
pretty tough but
a few painkillers and
got a lump of ice uh for two days and i
got battled out there for the last game
against um the fijian so
probably not the not the easiest game to
roll out with a flicky ankle
jason quick fijian dudes around but um
yeah it was it was enough to give me a
spot of the olympics and um
yeah how did it feel in there how did it
feel running around nah awful real awful
straight lines just straight lines
anyone stepped me or yeah
the first player
um
we were in a move and made a break and i
thought [ __ ] there's no way i'm sniffing
anyone so i just went straight at the
guy
but
um
yeah i was just probably lucky play
sort of went away i needed it to with a
sore ankle to nurse it for a few more
weeks
and did you think that was going to cost
you a spot in the olympics or did you
always have hopes that you were going to
be all right no when i did it i thought
that was me done um oh yeah i was i
remember line the other set foot up on
the post and dead robinson the whole
backstop was our dog she came home and i
was like
it's roaring in me like it didn't feel
that good
um yeah but i just spent two nights in
the game ready and
lucky enough at um you know a few
painkillers and
so it was enough to get me get me
there's one of those ones it was like a
probably three week injury
and i had three days so
if i could just get through that patch
it would be a lot better in sort of
three weeks so
did you notice it at the olympics ah
yeah we was reasonably stiff but i'd
never use it as an excuse like
um it was good enough yeah good enough
for you and how did you keep your
fitness up like you said you're off your
feet for
a real long period of time leading up to
the olympics one of the biggest sporting
events i guess you can have and
in a sport where you need to be
really really fit how did you manage
that
i've i've been i was like my whole
career i've sort of had like injuries
along the way that have stopped me for a
period of time so i sort of learned over
time to sort of get used to
um off-beat options whether it be a what
bike um swimming i had a walk bike at
home so i had a lot of dark days in the
garage just chipping away
the old uh wife rolls in just the lock
on her face
like a deep bug on the floor but um
i suppose the other things that make it
worthwhile when you get to the end point
and um
yeah there's a lot of offline stuff but
we're probably lucky now and now um
in our area there's plenty of options or
you know if you can't do one thing you
can probably do another
so
i was at a point and then you know lucky
enough that i could do some running
beforehand to to get me to where i
thought it needed to be and you were
always really naturally fit too weren't
you like a lot of guys can't really
cross over that um off feet conditioning
to on the field conditioning but you
always managed to be able to do that
yeah i find that um the naturally fit
comment like interesting because i
actually genuinely don't think i'll
naturally fit i just um
i'd sort of always done extras and you
know some guys will just do the minimum
that's asked of them and yeah yeah i was
one of those guys i probably wasn't as
naturally talented as
other guys so
that had to be my point of difference
and i kind of realized that it
this was a quite early stage
so i've just
made sure that whatever we do as a as a
team is
you know as to be a minimum and i'm
trying to always fit in a few more
so
yeah you'd say it's natural but
same time probably feel myself you've
worked hard for that natural fitness
some dark old days the mental battles i
know that
yeah that is tough eh and what was the
olympic village like yeah
it was weird but like i'd never been to
another olympics obviously so
i had nothing to really compare it to
i've been to
um games and you know it's on a much
smaller scale but yeah it was weird like
you go to the dining hall and um just
big long tables and then there's perspex
in front of you on either side of you so
you're almost in your own boat
that's a bit weird but
um there's still
thousands of athletes rolling through
the
the food halls and um you know heaps of
athletes around so
i presume it'd be a little bit different
to other olympics but you know still it
wasn't like we were locked all chained
together and couldn't go anywhere so it
was all good and we're you're obviously
pretty well known after your um famous
celebrations you do after the game so
did lots of people want to get photos
with you no where's where we're small
fish in that pond i think
things are
you were real small fish in that pond
though there's a lot of big names
rolling around i think some of the boys
that follow the people there's some um
pretty big dog nba players around and
um now we were real small fish in the uh
the olympic pond today were there any
new zealand athletes that you got along
well with yeah we got on with um billy
the surfer by steaming oh yeah yeah he's
a good roost we um he was in the same
hotel as us after we finished the um
finish the event so we had a few bruises
with him and he's good value he's just a
good raglan lad they're just uh
he's just stoked to hang out with the
boys as much as we're probably stoked to
hang out with him so
you know um it was cool we've you know
probably
connected with a you know some sports
that rugby probably potentially never
does so
uh it's a cool arrow because it's a cool
part about the olympics itself yeah it
looked like a real cool culture between
all the athletes in the in the village
so um yeah like you said that's
something you don't get anywhere else
and it must be cool no and i don't think
we really realized it until you sort of
start talking to the other sports and
you know they're probably intimidated by
rugby players in new zealand just
because
you know it's probably the the most
played and watched sport in new zealand
but you know if anything we're probably
just as intimidated by the other
athletes because we realize how much how
freakish they are
so yeah once the um you know once in a
few drinks or you know we got to know
each other as a as a wider team it was
actually really cool like when new
athletes would come or athletes that had
won medals would come back and do
hackers and
um welcome back it was actually yes it
was real cool it was probably you know
something i'll look back on and be one
of the coolest things i've been a part
of
that's awesome and how many hackers did
you get through you could have been
right into it well what's the definition
of being in the hacker
i was standing there but i speak i was
really
the curly one was it was actually the
new zealand team hacker so i didn't know
it to start with and the first time
first time we did it we had about 20
minutes to learn so i didn't know any of
the words yeah so i feel like it gets to
a point where you're disrespecting the
hakka when you uh
haven't learned it to the to the level
that it should be it so yeah you know
early on i'm probably
still clear of it but uh by the end i
was into it it was good
lucky you've got so much moldy heritage
in you that you can pick those sort of
things up naturally
yeah totally and i'm quite a vicious
looking human
oh good stuff anyway horse we've got so
much to get through what a career you've
had it's unbelievable so many twists and
turns but we need to go back to the
start i could imagine you would have
been
a very cheeky kid growing up but uh what
was your childhood like
it was pretty good i grew up in palmy um
my parents grew up pretty young so it
was like three when they split up um
so it was like you know disjointed but
um
it was all good and
um
you know just learned to make it work
and that's what it was so
you know i think at the same time it's
probably molded me into the person of i
am today so you kind of appreciate that
either yeah um
through school went to uh um probably
one of the rougher intermediates in
parmies i went to monreal
um so it's me and a lot of the island
boys which you know
looking forward to now again probably
molded me into being able to fit into
you know our environment probably
better than some other guys so yeah um
went there and then obviously went to
palmy boys where we had a
pretty good crop of players that rolled
through the same same time as me so
i think my sixth form year we
made top four we lost to christchurch
boys we were stacked at the time it was
uh
deco and colin slade and that crew so
um
yeah and then and then i suppose this
the serum form year we had a pretty
probably even more solid team but we
underperformed with crude and andre
taylor one of your boys
um
a few others but
uh
we're lucky in part me there's actually
a pretty good crop of players rolling
through this um i suppose aaron smith
was um he was at fielding so
a pretty good rep team the crossy boys
the warlocks
um sort of from there was that that was
probably where it all started for me it
was just um
i was lucky i went to a good high school
it was pretty decent at footy
um a few coaches just kept a little
white battler in their team and
i seemed to grow a little bit over over
the latter parts of high school were you
keen to play footy before you sort of
made the first fifteen and sixth form
was footy sort of the plan for you even
from a young age or not really
yeah i played it from a really young age
i never made any rep teams or anything
until about maybe under 16s or under 18
so yeah i definitely wouldn't have said
it was a planned pathway and at the time
a few moments ago but that was
sort of early 2000 2006 my last year at
school so yeah even rugby then probably
was nowhere near as professional as it
is now
um so
i can still remember my english teacher
just rocking me one day because we used
to you're probably the same at school
you'd go on all your sports trips and do
a little school in between yeah she's
just like you're never going to make a
career at a rugby you're not it still
sticks with me that she said there
um
but yeah at the time i
probably thought she was right to be
honest i was just wasn't the smartest
cookie in the jar so
i'll sort of bug it either way
was there a moment where you thought you
were just going to crack down and give
rugby a real good go like was there a
moment where everything sort of switched
for you
yeah i reckon it was that there's six
for me at the end of their sixth form
year sort of cracked into a
reasonably solid first 15 and i suppose
like men or two started sniffing around
when you're seven forms they're like
academies in that which
back then was a big deal to me but you
know it was not financially beneficial
or anything but once they start sniffing
around you're like [ __ ] maybe i um
you know half decent at this it might be
an opportunity to to make a career out
of it but yeah
you know i suppose i didn't really know
what i was going to do after school so i
just sort of rolled with the punches
worked for my old man as a sparky but i
was like i didn't want to do that either
so
probably to be honest all the things
along the way probably drove me to want
to train harder and footy
because it wasn't things that were sort
of enticing me too much along the way
yeah but mate you said you're you said
you're a battler but mate you were a gun
i remember going up against you at um
new zealand 20s and maybe 19s as well
trials
and you were you were an absolute wizard
so i think you made the 20s but not the
19s was it
no i made neither i um
trolled the last year the 19s and then
they went to 20s the following year but
um
i think that yeah that was when zach
gilford and um izzy dagg were the
outsides it was pretty is a pretty steep
crew to be fair um
if you're gonna miss out at least you
must have some decent players but um i
ended up getting called over to the 20s
and um in wales yeah
and they ended up winning it so i
actually got the medal there somewhere
so in about five years time i was 100
starting every game but i remember
you're coming up that trial too that 20s
troll you you were full back and you're
running an absolute mark obviously
didn't do enough to get izzy dag out of
the fullback jersey who was to be fair
and absolute wizard nah izzy dagg was
already playing full grain then on the
seventh circuit so i think there was
going to be a push and i think zach was
about
six months away from being an all black
so yeah it's gonna be a tough push
yeah true but you all but then you made
your uh man or two debut pretty quickly
after that didn't you
yeah i think i must have been maybe 20.
oh yeah would have been 2008 so two
years out of school you know i wasn't
straight away yeah i think uh cruds
aaron cruden and or andre was in the
turbos at school
um so i was a little bit later than
those two but yeah 2008 i think i
was my first game for for the turbos it
was uh um
yes it's a stacked wellington team what
was that jose gear
corey jane yeah i was [ __ ] my pants
how did you find it how did you find
going into that um man or two
environment
yeah it was good it was a lot different
to how things are now um
dave rennie was our coach and bruce
himmer they were
well obviously renz is a bloody good
coach
and he probably was really good for us
or he was really good for us um younger
guys just to teach our skills and
um that side of things but at the same
time
we basically finished the game and just
straight on the soup we'd um
there's a lot of piss ups
time it was probably saturday sunday
turn up monday
it was it was a good time their first
year you know when you're young and back
then you professionalism looked a lot
different to probably what it does now
but yeah it was uh looking back now
probably
could have got off to a pro maybe a
little bit better start but
um at the same time i've made some some
of my best mates who are um in that team
and you know i'm still mates with them
now so
wouldn't change it for the world and um
i suppose molded me into what i am today
you made the um then you made the new
zealand sevens pretty much that same
year right how did that one come about
yeah i played um the last half of the
season for um the turbos and then went
down to the national sevens and played
for metal too i think titch might have
picked me up from there so
um might have well asked me to go to a
camp i actually went to the camp and
made it and then
i got to dubai and bloody
nothing to it evac he steamrolled me and
um
i was named the team and never never
played a minute so um yeah that was what
you know i was talking before about um
injuries and things i suppose that was
my first real
serious enough injury to not play for a
few months so
went back home and regathered myself i
think for the rest of that next year
which would have been
2009 i just uh
i was in the academy with the turbos
obviously played for turbos but um was
still working because it was pretty
amateur back then so yeah i didn't
really my first game for sevens wasn't
till um i think the end of 2009 yeah we
went to london and um
how'd you find dealing with that injury
as a young as a young kid who'd just
been picked for new zealand for the
first time um no i think i handled it
well i just didn't um because i hadn't
you know hadn't had a taste of it i i
didn't really know
what it meant as in i was not going to
be playing sevens um
i was really lucky a a guy from palmy
sort of mentored me um quite a bit and i
i can clearly remember him saying like
you know you've you've had a sniff now
he he set me up on um when i got home
got me a wind trainer
um i didn't know what it was so it was
this thing he just sort of made me smash
out um bikes on a regular basis and and
looking back things like that probably
kept me
uh and good enough nick to operate as a
rugged player when i came right again
because
um at that age in palmy all my mates are
at uni there's a lot of um
a lot of good soup ups and things that
you know if i'd gone the other way i
could have just got sped out the back so
um
yeah i was probably lucky that i had
people to
direct me in the right the right way
that probably knew better than me at the
time
yeah so then you mentioned your first
tournament over in london that was the
following year what was that like going
into that
new zealand sevens
uh camp and then playing
on the big stage
it was epic um
i think at the time they they want to
run that maybe won like eight world
series in a row
dominant and
uh zar lawrence was the starting
midfielder i think at the time and he
got injured so it's just luck and then
back then i think from memory sort of
tits would only play as seven
and then those other
how many i think it was i didn't the
subs are different back then but those
other guys didn't really play too much
i'd come on in when it was 30 30 points
up and have a run around but zara
actually got rolled out of the
tournament um i'm sure my first game was
against um
i'm not one of those guys that can
remember games that well but i can
remember this it was against south
africa and now the very first play i
think we ran like a one-two cut or
something and i went straight through
and scored and i was like geez that's
what i needed because
the confidence was sweet after that
but um
yeah from there i was
you know i was just um i was pretty
flipped back then and we had guys that
could break a game anywhere i just sort
of had to be off the shoulders i just
played like a
probably a fullback would play in 15s um
and sevens and
i grew up watching guys like cullen and
that play played for seven so it sort of
like
indirectly molded my game off them then
he was fit as buggery so
um yeah you know if you're in the right
if you're fit enough at that time right
place right time usually yeah you and
callum exactly the same
not even close
but you obviously did impress titch and
then you did end up going to the
commonwealth games that must have been a
pretty unreal tournament yeah again it
was a bit weird it was in um delhi yeah
what was that like what was what's india
like uh we didn't see much of it to be
fair because at the time there was um
oh there's everything going on like i
think they hadn't even finished the
video so we got there and there was like
oh the debacle like we don't think we
we potentially didn't even leave the um
common games village over there from
memory so
yeah i suppose if growing up aspiring to
be at the commonwealth games and you go
there was a bit of a letdown but
at the same time we
as as a sevens team was it was pretty
epic we
obviously played aussie in the final
that were
i think they pulled back a few aussie
players at the time a few few sort of
names that they were burgess names at
the time and and we rolled them so
we had a pretty epic team looking back
as well though we i think bender
bender came back that was when zach was
in his prime um jose gear so
some pretty feasty animals to throw the
ball to which was good and that gate
that final went right down to the wire
two way was it a try on full time or
something yeah
we might have been up um
just up oh it's just
and then we scored yeah we scored on on
full time and you gave the aussies some
spray didn't you i didn't actually spray
them what is this putting the ball down
the scale where you stare but
there's a few floating photos floating
around to that which
make it look worse than what
wait that is one thing that you've done
in your career though you've always been
uh prone to a good sprout of the referee
or some players
it's got you in trouble before yeah i
haven't i haven't got the best roof in
that sense but
i always look back to
i um i was i went and talked to the
blues about some pd stuff a few um
feet well nothing about a month before
he left and
i said the first thing i said to him i
was like look
me as the rugby player is a lot
different to me as a person saying get
that off your skin and then we'll start
from here and you know they all had a
laugh because i think probably half of
them have played me and got it served so
um
it's a bit of a tough one
you'd say you're not proud of it but i
suppose it's just it's who i am as an
athlete and um
i'm paid to win games of rugby so if it
helps my team win and guys lose the guts
over it then see have you found that
when your people have met you that they
feel like you are a different person to
who you actually are yeah 100 i
i think a huge portion of people that
just you know just happened to know me
as a rugby player think that i'm an
absolute [ __ ]
um and i
if i'm honest i just say to them i say
to a lot of people if you've met me in
person and i'm still an [ __ ] then
sweet call me an [ __ ] but yeah don't
judge me based on how i play the game i
always look at guys like dane coles and
i'm like yeah people that don't know
colesy probably think the same thing
there's a lot of players similar
but
i think i'd be i'd be gutted about it in
the future if um
if people would meet me in person and
still thought the same thing but i don't
think that's the case unless there's
unless there's some underlying i need to
scratch the surface and do some more
checking
not a chance you're an absolute lad but
it is it is cool i love it how guys can
just be who they are on the field and as
soon as the game's finished then you
don't hold any grudges dude you're
you're straight into it after the game
and go have a chat to whoever you're
spraying or whether it was a referee
you'll probably go and apologize because
i know i know the referees cop it just
as much as the players
yeah i
i think a big part of that is when i the
era i was brought up and you know even
my old man in there yeah i think they
were just old school as in you know what
goes on the field stays on the field and
i i've sort of always had that mentality
but
i feel like the
the newer age player really struggles
with that um
and having gone back and had us played
some
modern cut last year with hawke's play
there's some guys that have held grudges
post the whistle i'm like well you know
that's not how i was
how i was taught i was sort of taught
what what goes on the first days on the
field but yeah because they might be
because of it then
sweet but maybe get to name your first
day yeah maybe before you judge me
mate i love it i love watching it it
always brings some good a good side
watch to games when you know someone's
after someone because of [ __ ] or
something like that i love watching cows
i love
watching you play it's it's good value
oh yeah but then mate you did move up to
the neckie so what brought that move
about
um
they had a fallback at the time his name
was casey stone and he was sort of
playing every game i'd sort of played
bits bits and bobs of their year and i
wasn't sort of like
a mainstay in their team and
um got a phone call from um the ceo at
the time and it was mark robinson who's
now the uh
ceo
and he said oh you know
we're really keen on
getting you up here having a look around
and i went up there and
you know i was pretty impressed by this
setup and
i felt like i was going to get more
opportunity
at fullback where i
wanted to play up there so you know it
was a tough decision because i think
meno2 had done a lot for me
from the academy side but if i'm being
honest i think
that move
really helped my career um
i might have got stuck in just the rut
of
play super playing soup up every weekend
and
maybe you know maybe i needed to change
just to get away didn't mean we didn't
soup up but
um
yeah it's just an opportunity to get up
there and play with some you know at the
time i thought there was some good
players up there
just meant you got to add in a bit more
punting
you know i met some lads that loved a
good punt so
it was a dangerous
do
combo
still punt nah i dropped some drabs i um
would have spent i would have wasted a
fair bit uh in my early part of my
career which you know i'm definitely not
proud of but um
you know taught me some lessons and um
still dabble every now and then but it's
just not not over used i think yeah um
you know i've probably sorted my sort of
my [ __ ] out a bit off the field
um with a bit more of a plan of where i
want to head and you know probably had
some a few wake-up calls on the way so
it was good for me as wake up calls with
a second chance i suppose so i was
throwing some money in the floor i
always remember you on the pump you'd
always have like a um
when they block your account if you if
you go over your limit
a wee restriction and then
like pretty much first down a month or
something get it you'd be done whoever
invented those restrictions and yeah if
you go hard or go home yeah yeah well
yeah that was probably yeah i went too
hard too early
on a lot of things but um
yeah probably the lads that i hang hung
around with um probably influenced it
all today
yeah
they definitely do we've had a few
a few good lads up there absolutely
loved it but what other memories from
your taranaki time that stand out for
you obviously had some good shield
success won the shield a few times uh
you won the premiership yeah some of the
somewhat best times in rugby were up
there um it was look at the eyes
um the people but people that have now
moved on and you know so clarky who's
our coach he was a skills coach here
um obviously robbo is now the ceo of new
zealand rugby
nikita who is a manager she's now a pdm
at sevens um
the players you know you look at some of
the players that have come out of here
or you know some of those boys that have
gone overseas or even like gaza bode in
there um
it was wicked and you know
big broadie i live with the big broadie
and cutesy who were just roosters
um we just looked a different life we
lived out of the beach and you know i
suppose it helps when when your team's
successful but we we at the time we were
pretty successful and we became quite a
dominant team
um i think we might have
played your mates from tessie in the in
that final and yeah one of the greats
yeah it was effort and i like you'll
still remember
i think we won the shield and then their
defense with a packed house um
you know it gives you goosebumps that
sort of stuff and i feel like that's
what rugby new zealand's about is
is um
you know provinces getting behind their
team so yeah um
i suppose from a rugby performance
perspective we were going pretty well
and i was going pretty well i was on the
back of a
a pretty epic team um
and then you know just
winning stuff usually helps how you feel
about things as well so
now it was um it was a cool five or six
years i think i was there but
um yeah wouldn't change it for the world
yeah mate you won personality of the
year uh five or six times down there too
so
right you've got you've got to have
you've got an absolute gap yeah until
you turned up
[Laughter]
i think when you
regularly get nude it's quite easy to
get that person out of your ear
like people think you're weird when you
shout these days so
yeah it made it easy
but one one story that i remember about
you after the 2014 final you had to fly
off to the maori's tour and
you've got your famous interview with
one news or whoever it was and
one of them one of the great yarns from
you
talk me through that one if there was a
night after we won the
premiership um
yeah i can still remember it like so
clearly yet
the words were coming out there clearly
at the time
so we must have played it was a night
game hey i think from memory we won
there yeah
yeah and then we went back to
jackson almonds place and all the tassie
boys came marty banks uh like fonzie
fonsi would have been there they are
funny was there yeah yeah karen
volunteer um and then obviously all us
boys and we so yeah we sent it um
and i still the sun was coming up and i
thought [ __ ] we've got to get to the um
we obviously worked out that we had a
plane then we needed to get to asap so
we ordered a smoke bomb then um i packed
my bag before i left and my my mum would
actually come to watch the final so she
had stayed i was living with mitch
crossover at the time yeah she'd come to
stay um
so i walked in the door and she was
standing at the door and she's like we
gotta go so i just basically walked in
pick my bag up to the loop walk back out
and then
i'm off to the airport so it was
probably i reckon about a 30 minute dry
patch before that interview but um
you could probably tell there all the
words that were coming out of my mouth
it was so good this is what i i've
always remembered since then i can
clearly remember saying to that reporter
you can't use that so that's why you
never trust some of those buggers
because uh yeah he didn't listen to me
mate i was i can't i still can't believe
that he did use that like
i know it was just a complete piss take
but i'm glad he did jesus
gave me some joy over the years the
worst part was that was that was say
like eight o'clock in the morning or
whatever time the flight was
and then we went to we arrived at
maori's camp and you sort of had like a
couple of meetings because it was a
sunday or something and they knew we'd
obviously played the day before yeah
hosts beach i've fallen asleep and the
scratcher got to dinner at like it must
have been just before six and i was
sitting there eating dinner and then my
phone just started roaring at me like
heaps of hits and i was like what is
going on pull my blower out and the boys
are just into me
and that video was on the chat at the
time and i just sunk i was like no
i just everyone else thought it was
hilarious obviously but yeah i wasn't a
yeah i was already in a hulk because i
was hung the bits and then that popped
up i was like wow
can't come back from this how did you
get on the media gig that that morning
surely they give you the pass yeah well
i'm unsure
there's a few red flags here that i'll
need to do some more research on because
to me it seems like a stitch up i was
just sort of young and naive i think i
got
got sucked in hey yeah geez so many i've
always had so many questions about that
video but it's good to get to get some
insight into it it still pops up on our
chat every
couple of months boys think it's
hilarious and i
just want that thing to disappear i
think it might have been you that
resurfaced the two you did
oh i love it i love it but you mentioned
your maori's tour and um something that
you obviously made a few times so how'd
you find it in that environment you've
got proud maori heritage in there yeah i
think like if i'm being brutally honest
prior to making the maoris i didn't
really understand my
my moldy side very well um yeah
and then
i knew i obviously had moldy in me
because
my grandparents and things but
after sitting down with my
my nana at the time and like she was
going through the family tree in there
and then um actually understanding where
i was from and and all that you know i
think it was a pretty cool part of my
life um yeah
you know even
post covert uh my wife and i we drove up
to
someone that in there so it's it's
things that i probably would have never
done
um had i not made the maoris and yeah
obviously i don't look they're maori if
that's
that's what people will say but um
you know i know i know for a fact that
uh you know i've got
a fair bit of maori heritage in me it's
just um
yeah
i'm bloody glad i
i sort of researched it a bit more and
got to understand it because you know
it's a big part of i suppose my my
family side before me which
is important to me yeah and you
obviously made it a few times so any any
tours or games that really stand out for
you and the maori's jersey
um
well the only one that really you know
we played some interesting opposition i
think one year into the uk and played
harlequins and not even sure if there
was an actual international but um the
the one of the last ones i went to we
went to japan and um
i think we smoked them the first one and
then the second game they almost beat us
and we we beat them right on full time
which was um it was pretty cool and
looking back you know
reasonably good team now and and i think
that was the start of the
their rise so probably looking back that
would be the one good times and then you
went down to the highlanders so how was
it down there obviously had a few
highlander guys on the podcast already
always seems like a real tight group of
guys who loved getting on the sauce yeah
and a few good yarns
how did you find it down there um well
yeah it was good i from a rugby scene
probably not so much because i didn't
play a lot um
i was there for four years and i think i
might have played
13 odd games with them oh really yeah
the first the first year i went down
there was post the um
the commonwealth games in delhi and i
got a stress fracture my back at those
con games so we basically turned up that
first year and was done the whole year
so it didn't play at all that year and
then that following year was sort of
when bender came on the scene and he was
a fallback as well so made life pretty
tough trying to sneak in there yeah and
then yeah i had the odd injury
in between that that probably didn't
help my cause but
yeah didn't play a lot but from the off
field side i love that i you know became
good mates with
some of those staggy boys and um guys
like bills and that they're you know we
had some amazing times together
um some good old sunday sessions and
there's not much to do and done this as
cold as if so
i wouldn't recommend trying to go down
there for some beach time or anything
but um
it was good i
i'm not sure
when i left there i i probably
if i was being honest i
was sort of happy to leave um because i
hadn't played the footy and yeah just
you know i didn't feel like i was you
know even the year we won it in 2015 i
could
sort of feel a bit on the outer um yeah
some wicked dudes here some
some boys that i'll uh
yeah some memories i'll cherish forever
yeah it's interesting to hear that you
felt like you're on the outer because it
is a it is a hard thing when you're not
playing a to feel like you're still
a part of the team and you're part of
the success when people talk about the
victories and things and if you're not a
part of it or you don't feel like you
did anything other than hold the tackle
bags
it can feel a little bit like that eh oh
100 percent and i you know i'm
again i think that's helped me now
because i'm really aware of it
within our sevens environment because if
you're not playing it's um you could
probably speak for most rugby players
you you play rugby to play rugby you
don't play rugby to
get the paycheck well some guys might
but get the page you can just hold some
bags um
so you can get frustrated i think but it
was a bit niggly but i can sort of i
feel for people that now get in that
situation and you can sense it
because you can you can see how easily
it can frustrate people and yeah
the lip drops and i'd say that'll be one
of the hardest things as a coach to keep
um
keep under reps is boys just dropping
their live
and it's such a even though it doesn't
feel like the players doing anything to
contribute being the opposition for
those thursday headouts or whatever day
it is that you're um having a hit out
against each other they play a massive
role into team success so the better
that side is
um the better they're likely to go in in
the game in the weekend so i know it
doesn't feel like they're doing anything
but they are actually having a massive
role but because they're not playing
under the bright lights um
you do feel like you're really not
contributing yeah and i think that was
that like um it wasn't about i actually
think that that was a big part of our
success was our
um
those guys which was was me we we
actually pushed the team quite hard at
trainings and we we never looked at it
like that but looking back you're like
yeah
like you say it um it's a big lead into
your team being successful and at the
end of the day that's that's what you're
there for um
i was probably just
to be honest i was probably just a bit
young and and i hadn't really worked out
that all out yet um
yeah but
yeah it's a good lesson i think so where
was the next move for you after
highlanders um so i had two since you
know two years
i went went to sevens and then i i think
i did another two years and then
yeah i feel like maybe after that
i potentially didn't get contracted so i
was back with sevens again
which would have been what it should
have been the real year oh it's 2016
before i went to italy and how was that
how was that how was rio well i'd go so
um
oh that's right here we go
here we go this is what we want
spill the beans on this one the form
player in new zealand i think you won
seven's play of the year
uh maybe the year before and you are
still in red-hot form but our best
player doesn't go to the olympic games
talk to me what happened what did you
say to him what did you say to him yeah
it's a hundred percent one well i don't
think i said anything i'm no i did it it
was just a funny yeah i think um
being the first on our seventh team
we've gone through lump perks and um oh
there's there were so many factors in it
but you know i'd had uh um legally
achilles the whole year but i'd played
every tournament through it so
for me that wasn't an issue but um
anyone that's been well you've been
coached by touch yes he just had this
has this thing in his head um
you know i had legally achilles and he
was like i just need to see if you can
get through it i was like mate i've
played every tournament basically every
minute this year this year
what do you need to see
do you want to do a big test for you
there you know i'll probably go write it
um
so it just got to a point where you know
i was
i didn't feel like
he was doing best for the team either so
you know might have said some things to
him i probably just stood up for other
guys in our team um at times and he
didn't like it and
you know maybe that was the reason i
honestly don't know
but um
no i wasn't selected for the team but
um he asked me to be the non-champion
reserve and i just
i'd lost interest in
um i suppose working for him as a coach
because
i just didn't think he was doing best
for the team um yeah
and
you know
people could take it how they want i
sort of respect the touch as a person
um for what he's done for sevens in new
zealand i just think maybe
he missed the vote away but in the in
the latter parts of his um of his
coaching but yeah i suppose i was a
sacrificial lamb of that year and
um it sort of panned out that the boys
didn't go so well at um at rio but i
don't think you know me not being there
didn't have anything really to do with
it it was just uh
probably you know there's a lot of other
factors in that year that that led to it
being how it is and uh
at the same time i think it's moulded
our team that we've got now um
and have been a lot better i mean in
creating better men which is
you know everything that i'm pretty
happy about were you surprised to see
them struggle at the olympics or did you
feel like
the environment and the culture wasn't
quite right to be going to an olympics
oh yeah i didn't i didn't think the
environment culture was right but
at the time i thought we'd still with
the team that we had um you know we
still should have gone pretty close and
to be fair
even though they lost to japan and only
scraped there is like the second
qualifier or whatever it was
um they almost the boys almost beat um
fiji and the quarter so
you know they weren't far as far off as
people make out but
it's funny you know i sort of always
believe things happen for a reason and
maybe that happened
for um
you know people using rugby and that to
look closer at what was going on or
maybe even they knew what was going on
it was just a
bit hard to move things on that lathe in
the preparation yeah and he'd called in
guys like sonny burl and all sorts of
big names hey so what were they like
coming into the sevens environment yeah
they were good um it was augie
uh sunny
liam miss him
what do we know but yes look gaza they
were great um
i'm not a coach so it wasn't up to me to
pick the team but if it was about buying
in there those guys are sweet um
i just think as a whole group we just
you know looking comparing our
environment now to
that environment it's like
it's light years apart um around there
you know we had a culture
um
with a
a players culture in the old regime
but it was like players management and
we just yeah we were treated like school
kids and it made things worse yeah
whereas now we're treated like grown-ups
and um you know grown-ups make their own
decisions and live and die by their own
decisions so yeah i think it's a good
way to be so you're allowed to eat red
meat now in the buffet yeah
yeah you can eat red
you know the funny thing is we're now
allowed to do everything and we do less
of it so
it's it's the same old energy if you
tell someone not to do something they
want to do it and then when they can do
it like oh this isn't fun anymore okay
look for something else to do
so yeah
we've always gone the other way can you
train with a head on clarky mentioned it
the other day reminded me of it but can
you train with a hat now i don't know
could you not you always used to wear a
hair training so you gotta mean
yo i haven't had any roles of not being
able to wear it so yeah
surely no we're definitely up to now
some protection yeah you need to uh some
of the places you're playing like 40
degrees nothing worse than a redneck
oh well geez that's some good insight
and then after that you moved to zabri
or when did the debris move come about
yeah i'd actually already signed to go
to
um zebra early on in the in that year
before rio so sort of like my plan was
go to rio and then um head overseas to
zebra but
some people looked at it like i was
leaving because of that but i'd already
planned to go away before that so it
actually worked out good because i had
and i had something i don't know what i
would have done because
it ended pretty abruptly i'd say
so
yeah i ended up going to the zebra
pretty much straight after that which
was another interesting sort of yeah
yeah go on well
signed a two-year deal and basically
they stopped paying us after about maybe
eight or nine months i think you've been
totally
i've been i played at eroni which was
the same team until they changed their
name it was a similar situation yeah
yes yeah yeah i knew i knew you had
something yeah so basically what
happened to you probably happened to me
yeah i'd signed the two-year deal um
sort of eight months into the was the
end of our season but eight months in
they'd sort of stopped paying us and
they were like missing payments and
things and i sort of like stuck between
a rock and a halfway so i thought i was
going overseas to sort of stay overseas
and then yeah
it got pretty messy in the end and i
decided you know i wasn't willing to
risk them not paying us i just didn't
trust them so
um
and i know this boy's going there now
and and probably heading there but
and they've been there since me and
there's been no problems but i just
wasn't willing to risk that it was um
it was too far away from home to
to just be living off uh living off
scraps i suppose so i ended up um
ended up bailing and coming back to new
zealand um and that was when i signed to
come back and play for fomento too but
they got yeah it got pretty messy in the
end they
zebra wouldn't they wouldn't pay me and
they also wouldn't sign my release and
i don't know no it works but like if you
come back to new zealand you
you basically have to sign a transfer
yeah to play back in new zealand and
zebra refused to sign my transfer
so i was basically back in new zealand
they weren't paying me
i had no team to pay for and i was ready
to play for the turbos but um
i think it got to like a week before
the first round um and they still hadn't
signed my release and i think some of
the heavy hitters had to had to come in
um
and basically threaten them to either
sign it or they'll be removed from
certain things because i think what
they're up to is probably no good so
got real lucky because i thought that
was me i was sitting in
i was sitting in palmy and i was like
man that's me done
yeah i'm i like i've got a team to play
for um but i'm not actually allowed to
play with them because legally i can't
so
um and at that time like when i came
back to new zealand that was when i
had first spoken to clarkey he was
coming back to take the
the seventh job yeah so um
i basically signed man or two in
sevens um coming back
but i couldn't play for either of them
and i had to play for men or two to be
able to play for seven
yeah and they had no ability to play
because the the piece of paper didn't
say okay crazy and they wouldn't sign it
so yeah how long how long
how long were you over there for playing
without getting paid
um i'd played the whole season so we'd
finish the
the pro 14 and i think it was a heineken
cup then yeah um
so it might have been like eight months
and i was there on a two-year deal
so it was sort of like
yeah i was niggly especially when you
get to that point in your career and
you're like
you know you go there thinking sweet of
well
i've always been brought up in new
zealand you have a contract and that's
that's the headline yeah
so did you get none of it or just bits
and bobs no they still well i got paid
up till that point but um
i finished i finished that year playing
and um
when i left that they already owed me i
think maybe two months pay and there's
two more to go for that yeah yeah yeah
so
still waiting for their money to arrive
the pigeon's got to drop it off
[Laughter]
yeah i remember i i sort of remember you
being at a crossroads where you didn't
have a contract and um then the seventh
lifeline sort of came so yeah you were
sort of looking for a super rugby gig
i'm guessing and none came so you went
back to sevens and i'm not sure if you
were
were you keen to do sevens again or did
you want to stay in the 15's game no i i
was so when i was over there that was
when i first spoke to clark when it was
sort of unfolding um he might have been
at london irish at the time he was yeah
yeah
he left me too go coach yeah get
yourself
always looking after the boys yeah yeah
so yeah he he was coming back he must
you know
he knew he'd have the job for sevens and
yeah uh i think it was just luck my
agent um
maybe
was his agent was with the same agency
and
just happened in convo they said
something i was like yeah i feel like
i've always wanted to play for teams
that you're passionate about yeah
for some you know for different reasons
but siemens for me was a you know a big
part of who i am as
as a rugby player and um you know the
thought of going back and and having a
sort of second sniff with it was
especially when i didn't think i ever
would um it was pretty pretty exciting
and you know clark gave me that
opportunity said he's going back um
we're pretty keen to to have you
involved with some good combos and i
think he understood
how much that team meant to me so it
wasn't um
yeah different coaches different views i
suppose and then you obviously hit the
ground running you're straight back into
your old sevens form absolutely running
a mark
yeah it was good like our team as a
whole i think started to take these
straps that year that i was in italy i
actually went over and watched them in
france and
you know they were battling they um
i think
they might have had scooter waldron as
the coach um
yeah it was sort of like a he was in in
between so he didn't really have clarity
on what he was up to so
there's some guys in there that
you know were just i think there just uh
to say they were in the seventh team
they
maybe didn't care as much as as other
guys that i've been involved in the past
so yeah kiki rounded up with crew guys
that were bloody passionate about a team
um which i think is very important and
um
and motivated to to see it get back to
where where it used to be
um so it's yeah it's been a
nice little uphill
trot since then which has been cool
[ __ ] yeah and you obviously had some
success the commonwealth game steven's
world cup the same year eh yeah
gold coast and san fran a couple of
unreal tournaments from you boys how did
you find those ones yeah it was epic it
was just like um
sort of like worked in in sort of steps
we kept building kept building and
on the way to building we were winning
stuff and you know i suppose the world
cup was
the final point of that building where
everything sort of clicked so yeah we
just you know we were lucky to win some
some big tournaments and
um even post that we
leading into pre-covert we were
we were humming i think we'd won
or made five of the six finals and
we're running pretty smoothly so
yeah um yeah we're lucky it went in the
direction that we all hoped it would but
there's a lot of hard work from a lot of
people behind the scenes to make it get
to that point
yeah and how did you find the covert
break obviously a lot of travels
involved and the seventh circuit is all
shut down you're you're not really sure
when the next tournament is going to be
it must have been tough times as a
sevens player having covert involved
yeah it was it kind of and and even
still now shut down our
world series probably doesn't even
really exist at the moment it's um
yeah sort of finding your feet with it
but for me personally covered um
you know it was actually
quite good for me as a person sounded
selfish but
we got married i think two days before
that lockdown
so i didn't go to the last tournament
which happened to be in vancouver which
was a hot spot about three days later so
i'd say some of the boys probably
brought code back with them um
and then yeah we had a wedding and my
now wife
she lived up in auckland at the time so
we didn't even it didn't even live
together and um it sort of forced
everything to happen so you know covert
there was niggly parts of coding for it
um for me as a rugby player but
for me as a person and probably helped
with the rugby
um passer um it was pretty good and a
covert baby was it no i think it was
just after it's just like we can claim
it as well
i'm down below there right
sure we have some practice in there
during combat
oh there would have been plenty of
practice
so now talk about sort of where you're
at now with the sevens and not really
sure what the next sort of plan is for i
guess the seventh team in general but
what's what's your plans are you hanging
around with the new zealand sevens team
is your goal to make the next olympics i
know it's only three years away now so
what goals have you got or plans ahead
so we also haven't thought too far ahead
um
on i'm sorry until the end of next
season yeah or i'd already um already
signed so
um
yeah i haven't thought too far ahead um
i'm still really enjoying it so
there's no reason to throw a tail in
when you're still enjoying it and i feel
like i've still got a bit to offer for
our team so
yeah i'll just see what next year looks
like we've got the um con games next
year and the world cup so there's still
things for us to look forward to um
and post that who knows whether i'm
still
playing good sevens who knows that's
probably clarky's decision more than
mine
um
but
yeah i'm still enjoying footy i
obviously had this season with hawke's
bay last season and actually really
enjoyed it so reignited the 15s flame
for me which
you know i didn't think i'd play 15s
again so
then there was another you know positive
of covert was i was able to play 15s
which
just you know i wasn't contractually
allowed to normally so yeah yeah i i
don't know i haven't really thought too
far ahead obviously had a massive
campaign with
leading up to the olympics and
sort of only had a week and a half to
re-gather myself so
to see what this next year
entails and you know hope that i can
still play good footy because
you're a long time retired when you
decide to pull pin are you what jeez
straight into coaching
but could you play fifteens now are you
able to play bunnings cup not normally
but um
it's usually a conversation you can have
with the coach and well with clark sorry
and
new zealand rugby and you know they were
pretty good about it last year and i
suppose is usually up to them i could
ask um whether they say yes or not is is
up to them and it depends on you know
what we've got coming up and and things
like that so yeah yeah see what happens
this year we've got another week uh get
out of isolation and see what happens
true and uh you've got your wee kratos
kitchen um side hustle going talk me
through this this is some of the best
food you'll see i love this kratos
kitchen
tasty stuff hey yeah how did it start i
think it was a coconut thing we were
sitting in covent and i was like man
because i've always enjoyed sort of
cooking and
um you know if i see something you know
we've always gone uh eaten out and
things like that so you see good food
you google the recipe and give it a give
it a hold yeah um and then i was like
well
been a
peanut footy guys well there's probably
you know some younger guys there battle
to cook so i'll
want to just chuck i'll just make a page
and and chuck some sort of semi-basic
recipes and tough ones here too but um
you know just good basic kiwi food and i
was like i'll just see how it goes and
got a bit of traction and it was more
for myself because i i used to google a
recipe
and then i'd lose it or just lose it in
all your tabs so why don't i just put a
photo picture so now if i need to make
anything i'll just go into the crowd's
kitchen page and um
get the rest it's basically my own
recipe but
other people can see it is it something
you'd look to do uh after rugby
i don't know i just
celebrity master chef
oh i don't know if i'd back myself just
to you know say they give you an
eggplant and some sauce
[Laughter]
bad
[Laughter]
well yeah i wouldn't be too flesh at
that side of it but um
yeah i enjoy cooking and
as long as i keep finding new things to
cook i'll probably keep putting it up
there what about a wee like cafe or wii
restaurant for you i always thought i'd
be called into a cafe but the chat is
it's bloody hard work and
you've got to really um work for your
cash so
fast
working for your kid
um
yeah changing the recipes every day i
feel like they'll stress me out i'd
rather just
cook what if you're like when i want
yeah
yeah there's easier ways to make money
with you eight modeling there we go
how have you found that you're obviously
a dead boy fan of jockey these days like
you're the you're the dan carter of new
zealand rugby
they're obviously looking for a
different um prototype i think what do
you mean
you're quite shredded now though oh you
know the old the old year was a bit
sloppy about it yeah you're shredding
that's what soup does to you yeah too
many too many soups you can really let
yourself go
yeah they're definitely looking for a
different um
setup how do you find it though how do
you find it in front of the camera
walking the catwalk are you comfortable
or is that
pretty awkward no [ __ ] no
um it's bloody intimidating i've said to
a few people why i reckon it's scarier
than any game rugby i've ever played
yeah standing waiting to go in the
catwalk you
get the wobbly knees it's pretty
intimidating
when you're undies like
you're looking at my setup like i
haven't got much to hide
well you'd be so much more comfortable
doing it nude though
yeah wow yeah around the right people
that's the thing
i'm all good around you know
the boys in there it's funny but
tough selling like people that actually
expect you to look half decent then you
don't
so who's actually looking at these um
watching you on that walk this catwalk
well they they usually do it at fashion
week so it's all i don't know people a
lot higher than me in the
the fashion world i don't know
i'm unsure
as better as them and then the thousand
cameras that they have sitting there
that usually spread it across a paper or
something
or when you're struggling down bloody
auckland main street you look up and
there's a billboard of your crook
carcass on there yeah it's true
but at least now it's um you're in a
team when you're doing it there's
usually a few of you boys doing it
together which must make a little bit
more make you feel a little bit more
comfortable
it's usually a pretty good laugh with
you know usually there's i think
two or three all black boys and two or
three sevens crew so we're all in the
same boat we're all
probably comfortable in our own skin but
as soon as you check us with some undies
in front of people we're pretty
uncomfortable so
um at least we're on the same boat
together yeah but not something you'd
like to do post footy i don't know if
you can maintain the carcass for that
long kenya
at least they're going for something
different
yeah well they seem to be these days so
yeah
yeah now they're probably like bloody
lucky that they got me on board with
them and cool they're a cool brand to be
part of um yeah
they sort of have a laugh which is kind
of me
um they don't take it too seriously
which is i suppose kind of me so
it suits the team up with them for sure
but we're talking post rugby is there
anything that you are that you are sort
of set on doing for post rug because i
know you've still got a few years left
but it's always a area which a lot of
players are you know it's a little bit
nerve-wracking coming to the end of your
career not really knowing what you're
going to do yeah i reckon it's one of
the scariest things that is the end and
i don't think people really realize that
you know you haven't been in rugby
environments the end can come at any
stage yeah i reckon i was lucky
you know for me that that that zebra um
the italy experience was a bloody good
wake-up call for me i thought i was
cruising at a stage um
um and i've said that to lots of people
like lots of players since i was like
it's all good when you're cruising and
you're getting
a contract every two years and it's
sweet but
when it sort of abruptly ends or you
think it might abruptly end and you
haven't got your [ __ ] sorted it's pretty
freaking scary yeah since then i've
actually done a fair bit of um you know
quite a few properties in that which
will keep me busy
when i'm when i'm dried up i'll just be
a maintenance man or something hopefully
do reno's on i'll just work around in
circles and do reno's until they
even if they're brand new renault i'll
go again um
but yeah i do my real estate papers and
and lock down and yeah i think that's
that's what i want to be involved in
i've
also got few my own properties and yeah
i feel like i'm interested in that that
sort of thing so i've i'm like a
qualified real estate agent but it's one
of those games that i think
you got to build a reputation and if i
do
this poorly while i'm still doing rugby
i probably
won't do myself any favors so hopefully
get into that when i'm done um yeah i
spent some i spent like the last four
years while i've been at sevens working
at asb bank so it was good for a better
like sort of upskilling i suppose
um
working out whether that's me or not
yeah i've i've since since italy thing
i've just made sure i've tried heaps of
things um obviously i'll sparky out of
school or electrician so it's been
bloody handy for me
with property in there and um
yeah i'm one of those people now i'm
just like sure if there's an opportunity
i'll i'll take it and see if i like it
yeah that's cool um and i reckon it's
the best thing you can do as a um as a
rugby player because sure we get some
opportunities and i don't think we
realize it until it's all gone yeah you
hear it all the time guys get to the
sort of the latter half of their career
and they start thinking oh [ __ ] yeah
it's coming around so i'm going to start
doing everything but imagine if you
started doing it from when you're a
young a and having your skills and how
much knowledge you would have gained i
guess
yeah and i like i always think to
you know early on i remember i didn't
even know how it was but they used to
say
go to a promo like with that many promos
yeah yeah and don't stand in the corner
like a num nuts and just
drink the free fizzy and leave and i
always made an effort to talk to people
and i've met so many people in those
those sort of things that you know
are friends now or
you know people that you still talk to
that you know one day might have an
opportunity so
i've i've tried to drill that into guys
you know when you're talking to them and
um and lock down our pdm got um andy
allistic to talk to our sevens boys and
i thought he was awesome he was like
he was probably a lot like sort of
i think i am as in but just talk to
people
take opportunities when they popped up
um
yeah i could suppressing you there was a
as a player because
it should be pretty scary i reckon when
it all wins and you don't have a big
crew of 20 odd players around you just
to laugh about [ __ ]
that that's that is great advice because
that is so true like people always talk
about knowledge but
what a lot of it comes down to
especially post rugby's contacts who do
you know who have you met along the road
who who rates you as a character and who
wants you to work for them when you
finish rugby and
mate someone like you with the amount of
contacts you've made the personality you
are you will have absolutely no issues
at all you'll be selling houses left
right and center back bloody hope so
damn otherwise you're coming to call you
you've heard it here first you will be
fine you're you're a good kid no doubt
but it's all also interesting hearing
you talk about the fear of losing that
contract because it's happened a lot in
the podcast guys have sort of got to a
moment in their career where it's all
been taken away from them and they're
thinking what is next do i need to
retire and that sort of sparked
something and given them that new life
for their career and they've ended up
going a lot further than they ever would
have imagined if they hadn't had that
moment i feel like you've done that as
well like you're your sevens game's gone
to a whole new level since there and um
it's awesome to see that something like
that can just it's sort of a switching
mindset and
have that sort of impact on players
yeah i agree i i just feel like you know
you look at well when you're younger you
look at rugby
or being a regular player as just rugby
but i i sort of look at rugby now as
it's rugby but it's also your off field
and they sort of complement each other
yeah i honestly believe that you know
since i've sort of you know not saying
i'm perfect now but since i've started
sorting my [ __ ] out yeah um
i've got a lot less to worry about when
i when it actually comes to rugby and i
you know actually i'm at peace when i
rolled out on the field yeah um and i
actually reckon it's helped my game so
you know
it's hard when you're young and
you know i suppose we don't mature to a
bit older as males are anyway but
um
when you're young and
we
you know like sort something out away
from rugby we get a
we what other job in the world do you
have a someone that's paid to help you
find another job like it's ridiculous
with the pdms
no one takes it up yeah um and that's
been the you know my biggest learning is
just make use of those people because
yeah if you don't she's uh
i'd say she's pretty sad life um when it
all ends it's all good now and it
happens heaps you hear it all the times
guys get to the end of their career no
money left they've spent it buying cars
and punting and all sorts of weird [ __ ]
and then
um
[Music]
they've got no no qualifications or
have a job and it's extremely stressful
i could imagine being in that position
and
it would be the most stressful thing
yeah i agree i it's but it actually
makes me nervous thinking about it and i
i feel like i'm
i'm pretty sordid um
don't get me wrong i'm going to need a
job i'm going to need a real good job
but yeah you know i've got a i've got a
roof to live under like i've you know
bought a house when i was first left
school and it was just chipped away my
my whole career so yeah
things like that at least now i know i
sort of set goals
real early on but didn't actually think
they're achievable like one of the goals
was you know all i wanted was a freehold
home because my theory was
at least a fire
if i get cut from rugby and i've got a
house to live and that's all that
matters like i've just got to find
enough money then to pay my power bill
and stuff so
you know i sort of had that goal in my
head and you know now obviously goals
move as as as you tick them off but
now it's ten freehold houses
it's a penthouse uh
vegetable per day
yeah no it's um it's it's scary but at
the same time i reckon if you sort it
[ __ ] it makes life way better yeah and
like i've you know i've got a
wife and a and a weak girl now so you've
got people that depend on you and as you
get older you get more people that
depend on you so it's nice to be able to
um make sure that
you know you can help fin for your
family as well mate that is awesome love
that love that chat wasn't expecting so
much about post footy but that is good
but what a journey like seriously what
what a career you've been it's been so
like all over the show you've been
sevens fifteens new new teams you played
for so many different teams you met so
many different people but yeah mate
you've been constant to who you are and
on the instagram i've put the questions
out as always and
um
you can tell what sort of a character
you are by how many questions came in
and they're all similar
in what they are
okay first question who's the worst
player to get one-on-one within sevens
oh
i'll go on our own team i'd probably say
like a
a joe webber oh yeah someone like that
but sure he can be in the washing
machine pretty quick with him
he's always had a gun stefan
yeah i'll tell you someone who who
tested me at the olympics was old um
sami kirevi because he can run over you
but he can also stick me down worse
he is a big strong man that one
oh yeah okay
you got so many questions about this
your famous celebration
first one is uh do you rest the balls on
the neck or tuck them basically what's
the technique
they must rest on the neck i'm not sure
i've ever actually
it's just it's just been where it is
there's no like position it's just
where it is is where it is
well they are i've got two
you're two venuses
oh yeah
either side of the neck bone yes good
clarity
okay well the next one how did the
celebration come about so how did that
start i actually
i can honestly say i don't know all i
know is that from her real early age
from uh
even from like club rugby i used to nude
up with you know if we want a trophy or
something so
um
i always think like
everyone always says you know don't
forget your roots i feel like it was my
roots so i just couldn't forget it
so
i've actually got a photo this is this
was before social media was like
you know what it is now and probably
wouldn't have got away with it but i've
got a photo i think we went to london
and we might have won the world series
and
in that tournament and i'm i've note
there with cups and things so i just i
suppose i've always done it and
just give the people what they want hey
good luck
that's it and people do love it it's
massive like so many people post photos
of themselves doing it all the time you
must get tagged in them everywhere oh
man i get tagged in so many and i just
laugh every time because i'm like i just
feel like sometimes people take
themselves in the world too seriously
and yeah
sports like we all play sport for the
good times and well i i think people do
um so
yes i actually really enjoy seeing her
when as usually like when the end of
break footy season also i'll get pumped
through cricket season usually get a few
i got a um
got one from the steel one yeah
yeah wendy fruit had the
the susan's out
oh that's good stuff yeah you can't beat
a little bit of nudity yeah and you've
obviously um driven that from ah it's
good stuff
all around the world it's good stuff
okay next one tell us some stories about
the great nick crosswell
oh crossy
to be fair a fair bit to the cross right
he was it he was at the turbos when i uh
when i started out and when i first
when i first sort of made it we used to
obviously
young
motor uni so we'd super after club footy
and usually the next day but the next
day you usually used to have um pool
sessions for the
you know adventure thing everyone just
played footy or no there and i said
every sunday i turn up either hungover
or still steamed
and i was just living with my mates at
the time because it was just a good time
and he's like oh just come live with me
so i ended up living moved in with him
and some other older turbos boys and you
know they weren't square we
sent it a fair few times but he probably
just pushed me more to the way i needed
to and yeah um
he's he was one of my best men at my
wedding so
uh you've got a lot of time for the
cross
oh how good is that
okay any backlash from that iconic photo
no you get the odd one of people that
spark up and say it's
out of order or something but
if 99 are saying all good then keep it
on i say keep it on
okay next one from phil burley one of
the greats ask him if he still has his
weak cat's tongue he used to get food
and drink milk milk out of a cat's bowl
nah it's not a part of the furniture
anymore
did it get removed
oh good stuff okay favorite all-time
punt to wind home oh oh you would have
some absolute beauty oh yeah i got one
very elegant
it's my favorite
i've met him a few times maybe yeah
cox plate reckon
storm's home
what this year or last year
oh yeah they won the court meal cut last
year we went to the hawke's bay races
yeah
full full day on the suit after playing
a ramsey shield game the day before and
um
obviously because aussie races are a bit
delayed we uh we had a full day at
hawke's bay winner right and then loaded
up on very elegant she she came home in
the corporate car [ __ ] it was good stuff
oh they're the ones i knew there'd be
something in there yeah treating myself
to some or we actually went up for thai
afterwards just to celebrate a big win
and that's how you became freehold
goal accomplished
it was one of yeah it was we were either
in or out it was like a freehold of
remortgage
[Laughter]
oh good stuff okay next one tell us what
you said to the touch judge in hawke's
bay 2009 to get a six-week ban
i didn't say what he said i said that's
the thing that still grates me
what did he say you said i think it's
quite bad i think he said to the point
where i was like
it was along the lines of like i wanted
to kill him or something i was like
but it was it basically became my my
word against his word and i was
i wasn't hiding to nothing i was 18. if
you saw my haircut at the time i was
disgraceful human so
i wasn't gonna win that argument
i definitely
you know
would have said some swear words but
i'm not actually sure i can't remember
no it's it's
very different hopefully
i learned my lesson sort of
oh good stuff okay
clarky's got one um what did he have on
on the flight home and could he show you
from a rowing coach
[Music]
what the washing machine just came back
so i could
some of it fresh in them what was it
it's a rowing suit oh yeah so um
having the reputation that i do
the boys were trying to get me nude on
the on the plane and i was like wow
that's that's not going to work because
i'm not
getting arrested off a plane
so um
i got a rowing suit and i got changed
into that and i was just yeah
well leaving it there
i've got a rowing seat
oh that's good stuff it must have been
some plane trip love it oh just bury
there
okay next one whose neck has been the
comfiest place to put your trouser snake
on
let me call it a snake it's more like a
slug um
go with
who was the first
trail was it i trailed your arsenal yeah
big tray good tasman neck yeah big fancy
nick
yeah he was a first i had no issues he
might have to rash but i had no issues
okay
who'd be one teammate you'd want your
custom celebration on your shoulders oh
i was going to say big sammy dixon
right around the neck wouldn't it yeah
i'd have a necklace but i'd just be good
for the lulls
you'll go sam dixon
just to give the people what they want
yeah
that's what they want no doubt
okay next one what's the back story to
your two thumbs up
there was no real oh the only
the first time i did it was just in
wellington yeah because one of the boys
at antonio kitty kitty but he wasn't
playing and he said off if you get a dot
look up and just give me two thumbs up
and he was up in at the cape town
so i did it and um
yeah it was a bit of a like just did it
just because he said to tell it and then
sort of crowd got him behind and i was
like almost just keep it on nothing and
then just kept it on and gets uh gets
people into the game so
as usual good good sign of if there's
some thumbs up then i'm scoring some
trials which is usually
usually good it hasn't been me
dry patch okay last one
what's the best piece of advice you've
ever received you've sprinkled lots of
good ones throughout this episode
looking forward to this
yes i know you do a bit of talking to
the youth these days around
advice and sharing your wisdom so this
this could be good
that's a great question
i'd go too
the first one would be just don't take
things for granted as in
from a rugby sense don't take what you
have for granted um and i suppose it
probably goes in life anyway
um
sometimes you think you've just got it
sweet and then you
do something to make it disappear or
just disappear so just don't take it for
granted because um
yeah so you know from a rugby sense
you're
pretty bloody lucky to have what we have
and to do what we do and get paid to do
it so
um i think the day you take things for
granted like that yeah you're done wow
that is good
you can't have another one can you that
was so good go ahead oh god i don't even
know go again okay
go again no no no no no
wait don't take things for granted oh no
here's another one here we go yeah like
because i haven't always been i
obviously haven't always been perfect
and uh
you know throughout my career i've you
know made errors or and not not doing
rugby but you know say the touch judge
thing yeah but i reckon the one thing
you can do is if you stuff up just admit
it and um
and be better for it um because
if you try to run from it she's a
she's a long road to your running
so
usually if you're doing like you know no
one's perfect and like i'd say look at
me as an example or yeah anyone that
knows me we've just you know
done some dumb [ __ ] and
um still here but i suppose you just you
just gotta front it 100
oh mate that's two quality pieces of
advice as as i expected but
mate absolutely appreciate you coming on
the podcast mate it's been some journey
i love my time playing within the nike
we had some of the best times of my
career up there um loved every minute of
the multi very some some unbelievable
maltese landed and
some syndicates were on fire but it's
been awesome following you since our
times in the necky watch your career
progress
and all the way to the biggest stage and
one of the greatest lads to come on the
podcast i really appreciate you coming
on mate cheers to ever thanks for having
me you're a good kid appreciate it
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what
[Music]